[Musique]
par les enfants on les chope
patron j'ai un travail terrible ce soir
j'ai promis à cornichons de l'aider à
mettre tout en ordre dans la roulotte
allons vite au travail de l'ours au
courage merci aux
propos mme
[Musique]
hou là là il me semble qu'il y encore
plus de vaisselle qui errent attrait
chan au centre et nous vous êtes indien
bonsoir les travailleurs
[Musique]
heureusement que tu viens nous
n'arrivons jamais tout ranger tu sais ne
nous affolons pas vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir
attendons et voyant salle la fin
couronne l'avre vous verrez dada vous
verrez j'ai l'habitude quand j'étais
petit j'ai des ma maman je me souviens
[Musique]
jaune
souvignon
oh
je te petit
jeu
sous vivant
2 bat petite maman chérie
un
petit
on va faire les courses
il ya plus de là
on a tous
en nous
moi je réponde à
j'y cours
maman joli haut
et vite jal
jusqu'à la berge bruit
quand
j'étudiais year
[Musique]
masri milliards
9 de monde
euh tu abuses hier avec moi
ou genre
répondeur
jeu
moi ma structure au camp
bon je vous le
savoir lire
écrire
ma soeur emilie à
jouer à la marelle ou en
en sont hors jeu la dre l'a vu son
but il ya longtemps
mais je n'oublie pas
que ma maman
a toujours aidé venir de moi
oh
[Musique]
oui vraiment
bien se conduire
eux c'est faire plaisir
à sa chute
maman
[Musique]
bravo nounours bravo je ne vous
connaissais pas ces talents et je vois
que vous ètes abraham nounours merci
chers dada pour vos compliments mais
vous auriez mieux fait de nous et du
1 au long les enfants au lui
bonne nuit petite pépite à rentrer vite
chez toi
ô
étant vite mon petit cornichons oui
bonne il nous
est la nuit ferment honore sa mère si
cheikh anta à vous aussi
[Musique]
patron nous pouvons nous en aller tout
est en ordre en bas nous avons fait du
bon travail
bravo nounours en route bonne nuit des
enfants embrasser bien fort vos parents
allez vite vous coucher n'oubliez pas de
faire votre toilette lavez vous les
dents
une fête de boer eux
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]